wanted you morning Sheila morning boys
Lindsay of Lindsay's mirror Depot called
she wants to see the commercial well
that would make three of us shall we
one minute the third floor is calling my
buttholes mate yeah Oh Frederick Wow
it's got that fly well I declare I'm
coming to poop on you actually poop NCAI
do both I'm talking to Sam now I don't
know what you're doing
yeah don't with me oh well if you're
traveling you are going to need your
suitcase well I thank you my good man
course keep it outside to sleep energy
[Music]
the phone lines are up so distributed
sensor works and n Wi-Fi password also
make sure everybody rate slander and
proposal as well
[Music]
Tim it's over it's over the third floor
is over yeah slow down
what are you talking about okay so say
what that they're speaking at the pool
and then I witness a bunch of people and
it's a businessman leave it I was this a
- words slow down what's wrong
we can't poop my third floor anymore
kick it Thank You me you're freakin
Frogger than me who cares
ah when they ask you